[Music]
dr. taste upended the stalker thought
was all and [ __ ] tiny Tina one of the
most it's hard to say that she's a crazy
character because like every character
in Borderlands is like insane but give
us a little rundown of of Tina and kind
of how you came up with that way so Tina
is based on a friend of mine Anthony's
named Christina who is actually insane
and so she flattered Oh does she take
offense by that oh she thinks it's
awesome she she loves it she's she's one
of the waiter people that we've ever met
we love her so it's kind of a mixture of
her and then just sort of the way that
Anthony and I are goofy with each other
and like the humor that we share we I
kind of just injected Tina with a bunch
of that and um yeah and the voice is
something that I've kind of been doing
just when it like it's funny because
when I if I feel like weird or whatever
I'll kind of do like a Tina voice it's
just kind of it boys as I've already
kind of had and I just applied it to her
so I imagine you in the studio and your
brother is out there listening to you
does it make you more relaxed that you
have a family member listening to you or
does it make you more nervous I feel
like if my brother was there I'd be like
more nervous to open up I don't know I
was initially prettier it was also my
first real acting gigs or not well voice
acting gig and and so initially I was
nervous but now it's great because I'm
if I mess up then he just tells me that
straight up and it was portable doing it
yeah I pretty much she's like I was
really bad I'm like thanks Anthony but
yeah so it's a lot more comfortable now
and everyone that works at oka Tron and
everyone here box which is really nice
so yeah they're really really sweet and
really supportive Mark's shaking his
head though so yeah it's a super
comfortable environment to just like
play and experiment with her how much do
they let you ad-lib and kind of just
riff oh however much I want yeah he
really likes it when actors ad-lib it's
like his favorite thing so he really
loves hearing how people are gonna
deliver lines he's it's it's fun working
with with him especially because I think
there are some writers that have a very
specific thing in mind of how they want
you to say the line and he doesn't he's
just like us might be crap I don't know
and then
hear someone say it he's like oh it's
funny you made it funny and it's a lot
more collaborative I'm the complete
opposite like I love having it like I go
off the writing like I don't like out
living as much uh just one last question
what other voices do you do in the game
I am primarily Tina but then I also am
the bane I'm half the bane the most
annoying gun so the laugh is is my
horrifying voice awesome thank you so
much guys
Ashly Burch mark petty thank you guys
for joining me tell me your thoughts on
these awesome people hashtag GameSpot
III get some cuts on the way comp it's a
clue
[Music]